.
"THE FIVE" NOW.
>> HELLO, I'M GREG GUTFELD HERE
"THE FIVE."
>> GREG: YOU NEVER KNOW WHEN YOU
NEED A DOSE OF PATRIOTISM UNTIL
YOU GET IT INTO YOUR SYSTEM AND
THEN IT'S LIKE, WOW!
THAT FELT PRETTY AWESOME.
WE'RE REFERRING TO AN AMERICAN
OLYMPIAN GETTING A TON OF
ATTENTION FOR ALL THE RIGHT
REASONS.
TAMARA MAKING HISTORY IN TOKYO
AFTER BECOMING THE FIRST BLACK
AMERICAN WOMAN TO TAKE HOME A
GOLD MEDAL IN WRESTLING.
UNLIKE SOME OTHER WHO HAVE USED
THEIR PLATFORMS TO PROTEST
AMERICA SHE HAS NO PROBLEMS
PRAISING OUR COUNTRY.
SHE'S SAYING -- I LOVE THE U.S.
I FREAKING LOVE IT THERE.
I'M SO HAPPY I GET REPRESENT
USA.
SHE THEN WENT ON TO GIVE THIS
EMOTIONAL RESPONSE AT A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
>> I'M VERY HAPPY AND I KEEP
TRYING NOT TO CRY BUT IT KEEPS
HAPPENING.
>> WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE
POPULARITY OF THE SPORT AND FOR
ALL THE YOUNG GIRLS OUT THERE
THAT WILL SEE YOU AND FEEL
INSPIRATION?
>> IT MEANS THAT THEY SEE
SOMEONE LIKE THEMSELVES ON THAT
PODIUM.
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE A FEMALE
DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN'T
ACCOMPLISH THE BIGGEST OF GOALS
AND BEING AN OLYMPIC CHAMP IS
ONE OF THE HARDEST THINGS I HAVE
EVER DONE IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
AND I CAN SAY IT'S WELL WORTH
IT.
>> GREG: SO OBVIOUSLY, THE SHEER
POSITIVITY COMING FROM THAT
YOUNG WOMAN IS WELCOMED RELIEF.
AND WE ALL KNOW IT'S THAT
ATTITUDE THAT WILL CARRY HER
THROUGHOUT LIFE.
PEOPLE MIGHT MOCK THE POWER OF
POSITIVE THINKING BUT I DARE YOU
TO FIND A FAILURE AMONG ANYONE
WHO EMPLOYS IT.
OBSTACLES BECOME ADVENTURES AND
SETBACKS BECOME CHALLENGES.
CONTRAST THAT WITH THE
ACTIVISTS' PERSONA WHICH
DICTATES ANY EXPRESSION OF GLEE
OR GRATITUDE IS VIEWED AS
COUNTER TO THEIR MISSION.
EVERYBODY MUST BE PART OF THE
GREAT STRUGGLE AGAINST THE
PERCEIVED AGGRESSION CAUSED BY
THE EVIL COUNTRY YOU REPRESENT.
LAST NIGHT THIS GREAT ATHLETE
REMINDED EVERYONE WHY THE
OLYMPICS IS SO SPECIAL.
IT SHOULD BE THE GREATEST TIME
OF YOUR LIFE FOR YOU AND YOUR
COUNTRY AND I'M SAYING THAT AS
SOMEONE WHO HATES THE OLYMPICS.
I'LL JUST STARE.
SO KATY, NOW, THAT'S LIKE OLD
SCHOOL OLYMPICS, LIKE YOU
REMEMBER GROWING UP.
HAPPY ATHLETES.
HAPPY WINNERS.
PATRIOTISM.
EVERYBODY IS ADORABLE.
>> I JUST LOVE THE WHOLESOME
GOODNESS AND GRATITUDE THAT SHE
SHOWED TO HER COACHES, HER OWN
HARD WORK AND WORK ETHIC, TO HER
ABILITY TO TAKE ON CHALLENGES
AND OVERCOME THEM.
I FEEL LIKE WE LIVE IN A TAME
WHERE PEOPLE THINK TAKING
CHALLENGES ARE BENEFICIAL, IT
ALLOWS US TO OVERCOME ADVERSITY.
HER DAD IS AN IMMIGRANT FROM
GHANA WHO CAME HERE SOMEWHAT
RECENTLY AND TO WATCH HIS
DAUGHTER TAKE HOME A GOLD MEDAL
TO REPRESENT THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA IS AMAZING.
IT'S WHAT EVERYBODY NEEDED AND I
JUST LOVE EVERYTHING ABOUT HER
AND I HOPE SHE GETS TO GO BACK
AGAIN.
THIS WAS HER FIRST OLYMPICS.
ALSO IMPRESSIVE TO GO IN AND WIN
GOLD THE FIRST TIME.
CONGRATULATIONS TO HER AND THANK
YOU GIVING US ALL OPTIMISM AND
GRATITUDE.
>> GREG: DOES IT STRIKE YOU AS
SAD THAT SHE'S ACCOMPLISHED MORE
THAN YOU HAVE IN YOUR NUMBER ONE
ENTIRE LIFE?
>> A NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER -- I
HEARD SHE MIGHT BE DOING A
LITTLE FOX IN A FEW DAYS.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR THAT INTERVIEW.
>> I'M EXCITED.
TOMORROW MORNING SHE'LL BE ON
"AMERICA'S NEWSROOM" TOMORROW.
WE'RE SO EXCITED TO HAVE HER FOR
SURE.
>> I'LL BE WATCHING THAT BECAUSE
SHE'S JUST BRIMMING WITH
EXUBERANCE AND IT'S CONTAGIOUS
FOR ANYBODY WHO WATCHES THAT
WHAT I'VE NOTICED, THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE HAPPY ARE ALSO
PATRIOTIC.
IT TAKES HAPPINESS TO BE
PATRIOTIC BECAUSE HAPPINESS IS A
KEY COMPONENT -- IT'S KEY TO
BEING GRATEFUL.
WHEN YOU'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
LIVING IN THE MOMENT AND YOU
APPRECIATE THE BLESSINGS OF
EVERYTHING AROUND YOU AND THERE
IS NOWHERE, WHERE THE BLESSINGS
ARE AS PLENTIFUL AS THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
SO PEOPLE THAT ARE GRATEFUL
EXPRESS THAT AND THAT'S
INSPIRING TO OTHER PEOPLE WHO
ARE WATCHING AT HOME.
WE DON'T WANT TO FEEL GUILTY
WHEN WE WATCH THE OLYMPICS.
WE COULD JUST WATCH CNN IF WE
WANTED TO FEEL THAT TIME.
>> OR THE "NEW YORK TIMES."
>> DID YOU NOTICE HOW THIS
FEMALE GOLD WIN FEMALE WRESTLER
HASN'T BEEN COVERED ON CNN, NBC
NEWS OR CBS.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
SHE CHECKS ALL THE BOXES.
SHE'S BLACK.
SHE'S FEMALE.
GOLD MEDAL WINNER.
ONE BOX SHE DOESN'T CHECK.
SHE'S NOT PATRIOTIC.
SO THEY CAN'T PUT THAT STORY ON
BECAUSE -- YOU.
>> MEAN UNPATRIOTIC.
>> SHE IS PATRIOTIC.
>> RIGHT.
THEY SELL THE STORY OF BLACK
ATHLETES WHO ARE UNPATRIOTIC.
THEY SELL STORIES OF BLACK
ATHLETES THAT MAYBE DIDN'T PASS
A DRUG TEST.
THIS STORY IS NOT THAT.
THIS IS ALL BEAUTIFUL BE ALL
PATRIOTIC AND THEY ARE NOT
SHARING THAT WITH THE AUDIENCE
AND THAT'S SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT AND WHY HASN'T JOE BIDEN
BEEN SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT THE
OLYMPICS?
WHY IS THAT?
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP WERE
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW, HE WOULD BE
TWEETING, HE WOULD BE
GALVANIZING US TO WATCH.
IT WOULD BE UNIFYING.
HE WOULD BE ON TWITTER, BIG WIN
FOR THE FEMALE ROLLERS IN TOKYO.
THE PRECISION AND BEAUTY AND
POWER THAT THEY DIP THOSE OARS
INTO THE WATER.
THEY WILL HAVE A BIG CELEBRATION
BACK AT THE WHITE HOUSE WITH THE
ALSO BEAUTIFUL FIRST LADY
MELANIA.
GO USA.
>> HE WOULD KNOW THE MEDAL
COUNT.
>> THAT'S ALMOST VERBATIM.
WERE YOU WRITING FOR HIM?
I'M DEEPLY IMPRESSED.
GERALDO, IT REMINDS ME OF
MARILOU RETTON.
REMEMBER HER?
>> SURE.
CAN I SPEAK MORE BROADLY
REFERENCING MARILOU RETTON, A
GREAT CHAMPION.
>> GREG: HOW DARE YOU.
>> I'M AN OLD FASHION PATRIOT
AND I THINK YOU AND KATY BOTH
MADE A VERY ELOQUENT
PRESENTATION IN THAT REGARD.
I ALSO BELIEVE IN THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
PROTEST.
THEY CAN USE ANY PLATFORM THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO.
THEY HAVE TOTAL FREEDOM, BUT I
AS AN OLD FASHION PERSON, YOU
CAN TELL BY MY MULLET, I REALLY
FEEL THAT THE OLYMPICS IS NOT
THE APPROPRIATE STAGE TO BE
NEGATIVE ABOUT YOUR COUNTRY.
THE REASON I LOVER THE OLYMPICS,
ONE OF THE REASONS, ASIDE FROM
THE SUPERB ATHLETICISM, THERE IS
THE FLAG OF THIS COUNTRY -- PICK
A COUNTRY, FRANCE, AFRICA, AND
ALL OF THIS, IVORY COAST,
HOWEVER YOU SAY IT, BY USING THE
OLYMPICS AS A STAGE TO MAKE A
POLITICAL POINT IS A CHEAP SHOT,
AND I REALLY BELIEVE, FOR
INSTANCE, WOMAN SOCCER TEAM, AND
HOW THEY STARTED THEIR RUN,
THERE WERE SO MANY AMERICANS
THAT I KNEW WERE CHEERING SWEDEN
IN THE THREE ZIP ROUT, I KNOW
IT'S A VERY CONTROVERSIAL
STATEMENT AND APOLOGIZE IF I
OFFEND YOU, BUT I DE TEST PEOPLE
GRABBING THE OPPORTUNITY OF THAT
STAGE AND CHEAPNING IT.
I DON'T EVEN LIKE THE KNEELING
AT THE FOOTBALL GAMES.
I SAW THAT THAT KNOCKED OFF FROM
THE NFL FROM ITS MOMENTUM.
>> IT'S A DISTRACTION.
IT WOULD BE LIKE US ON THE FIVE
ALL OF A SUDDEN THROWING A
FOOTBALL IN THE MIDDLE OF A
POLITICAL DISCUSSION WHICH I
THINK WE SHOULD DO.
PEOPLE USED TO, I BELIEVE.
>> GREG: DANA, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO ASK HER?
>> DANA: THERE ARE A FEW THINGS.
I THINK THE ADVERSITY POINT IS A
GOOD ONE.
HER FATHER ACTUALLY DIED WHEN
SHE WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL AND HE
WAS ON HIS WAY BACK FROM ONE OF
HER EVENTS, AND SHE ALMOST QUIT
THE SPORT ALTOGETHER BUT THEN
SHE SAID SHE WAS INSPIRED TO
PICK HERSELF BACK UP.
SHE SAID SHE LOVES GETTING BEAT
UP AND SHE LOVES BEATING PEOPLE
UP.
SHE TOLD HER COACH, I'M NERVOUS,
SCARED, FREAKING OUT.
HELP ME.
SOMEHOW SHE WAS ABLE TO TAKE
THAT ANXIOUS ENERGY AND
TRANSFORM IT INTO SOMETHING
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
SHE KNEW HOW TO BITE THE MEDAL.
THE OTHER THING IS, WITH HER
PRIZE MONEY SHE'S GOING TO BUY
HER MOM'S DREAM, WHICH IS TO
HAVE A FOOD TRUCK.
I THINK SHE SHOULD CALL IT GOLD
MEDAL BARBECUE BECAUSE
APPARENTLY, GREG, IT'S BARBECUE
SHE'S A SPECIALIST IN.
>> SHE LIVES IN TEXAS.
IT'S GOT TO BE BARBECUE.
WHAT ELSE WOULD BIT?
IT WON'T BE A SUSHI TRUCK.
THAT WOULD BE MY DREAM TO OWN
BARBECUE TRUCK BUT I WOULDN'T
HAVE ANY CUSTOMERS.
>> DANA: YOU WOULDN'T BUT SHE'LL
HAVE A LOT OF CUSTOMERS.
SHE'S FULLY H